Vsauce!
Kevin here, with 64 kittens, 2 wallets, 1
coin -- and some math that lies to you.
Some of you are gonna be okay with that, because
you’ll already have found cognitive shelter
in the unknown.
Others won’t even see it.
I’ve made a lot of videos about different
probability problems and paradoxes -- Russian
roulette, Monty Hall, the Birthday Paradox
-- and… we’ve solved them all.
But what happens when the math is right and
there’s still a paradox?
What happens when you KNOW a right answer
is actually wrong?
Wallets.
Imagine I choose two people randomly as they
walk on the streets of Manhattan.
I give them the option to play a game.
They compare the amount of money in their
wallets, and the person with the LOWER amount
wins all the money in the other wallet.
Does either person have an advantage?
The math says NO.
YOU say YES.
But wallets can wait.
Let’s start with coin flips, the probability
of which is perfectly quantifiable.
I’ve got a coin with YES on one side and
NO on the other.
The odds of getting a YES or NO are 50/50…
other than the 1 in 5,000 chance that it lands
on its edge.
So 50/50.
The odds of getting YES / NO / YES / NO / YES
are .5 raised to the power of 5, or .5 x .5
x .5 x .5 x .5 = .03125.
Cool.
The odds of getting 5 YES’s or NO’s in
a row?
WELL!
Now.
That’s… also .5 raised to the power of
5.
Every combination of YES and NO has exactly
the same chance of occurring.
But you KNOW deep down that getting 5 in a
row doesn’t happen nearly as often as a
mix of the two.
How can two things have the exact same probability
of occurring, yet occur less often?
I can explain….
WITH KITTENS.
Real quick, this Vsauce video is sponsored
by Vsauce.
The brand new Curiosity Box by Vsauce will
give your body a shirt.
Your hands a puzzle.
Your eyeballs illusions.
Your bacteria a kit.
Your brain a book.
And Curiosity Curriculum cards detailing the
science and activities behind it all.
So subscribe now to the Vsauce Curiosity Box.
And let Vsauce into your home.
You have a litter of kittens (or your cat
does) -- let’s say the cat has 4 kittens,
and there’s a 50/50 chance of each kitten
being a boy or a girl.
Every combination of kittens is .5 raised
to the power of 4, or .0625 -- but the most
common combination isn’t the equal split
of 2 boys / 2 girls you’d expect.
It’s actually 3 of one and 1 of the other.
When you map out all the possible combinations
of kittens, there are 16 combinations that
all have the same exact probability of happening
-- but getting a perfectly even 2 of each
happens in just 6 of the 16 combos, or 37.5%.
A 3-1 split happens in 8 of the 16 combinations.
50% of the time you’ll get 3 and 1, despite
the 50/50 math telling you everything’s
got the same chance.
Simple math tells you one thing, but combinatorics
using that math tells you another.
Okay.
Let’s go back to wallets.
Do you have an advantage in this game?
If your wallet has less money in it, you’ll
always win MORE than that amount by taking
the other wallet that has more money in it.
If YOUR wallet has more money, you’ll only
lose what you’ve got.
Since the game is totally random and neither
player knows anything about the other, the
probability of each player winning and losing
is the same -- but when you win, you’ll
get more money than you LOSE when you DON’T
win.
So you’ve got a major advantage in this
game.
But when the other player loses, they’re
only losing what’s in THEIR wallet.
And when they win, they’re winning MORE
than what’s in their wallet.
THEY’VE got a major advantage in this game.
The question is: How can two players competing
against each other BOTH have an advantage?
Here’s how…
THEY CAN’T!
If there are two outcomes -- X and Y -- we
can assign probabilities to each, and adding
those probabilities together HAS TO add up
to 1.
Having an advantage would mean a probability
greater than .5… if X and Y are both greater
than .5, you’re gonna get more than 1 when
you add them -- and that’s probabilistically
impossible.
It would be like betting on a sports game
where Vegas says BOTH teams are favored to
win.
It makes no sense.
And look.
Maurice Kraitchik’s payoff matrix for the
wallet game shows that the two players have
exactly the same probabilities of winning.
It really is 50/50, and the math proves it.
But the logic of each player is… flawless.
It’s unassailable.
Neither player CAN have an advantage, but
both players have perfectly reasonable logic
suggesting each one DOES have an advantage.
The problem here is that you NEED to know,
and discarding information makes it easier.
I’ll talk more about this in a future video
-- but think how much easier this problem
gets when you just trust the math, or you
go with logic and your gut.
Reducing a complex scenario between math and
reality lets you eliminate the paradox and
proceed comfortably.
But when faced with explaining the faulty
logic of these two wallets, some of the greatest
math minds could only proceed comfortably
knowing that they... couldn’t really tell
ya.
Kraitchik first proposed the problem in 1944
-- and The Two Envelopes Paradox was conceived
as a derivative of it in 1953.
Nearly 80 years later, we don’t have a clear
answer to why the math works and the reality
doesn’t.
You can factor in discrete distributions,
random variables, or continuous density functions
to get deep into the math -- but the TRUTH
is that probability tells you one thing, and
logic tells you another.
The moment we know something about the players
in the wallet game, we enter the territory
of the subjectivistic interpretation of probability
-- the Bayesian notion of utilizing information
about a problem to assign possible values
to different frequencies of outcome.
So like, if one player is 18 years old, you
might think they’re less likely to have
a lot of money in their wallet because younger
people are more likely to earn less, carry
cards or pay with their phones.
If a player is older and on vacation in Manhattan,
their wallet might be more likely to be LOADED
with cash.
But in our wallet game, we don’t know ANYTHING.
We have math that proves it’s equal and
logic that proves it isn’t.
We have such a strong tendency toward equiprobability
that when logic tells us we’ve got an exception
to a normal 50/50 rule, it shocks us into
taking it too seriously.
It messes with our uniformity belief enough
to make us trust it.
Martin Gardner wrote that Kraitchik was “no
help” about logic in the wallet paradox.
Gardner couldn’t explain it, either.
All these papers by very smart mathematicians
get into the math but just discard the very
real logical objection.
Often by concluding with something along the
lines of, "uhhh... don't play this game!"
No one can explain why without making a few
assumptions.
Maybe the wallet game is just an antinomical
paradox that we have to live with.
But the coin flips and kittens?
That’s the type of math that can mislead
you.
Probability just isn’t frequency -- and
frequency is reality.
So life may be a series of 50/50’s, wins
and losses, yeses and nos -- that lead us
all to wildly different outcomes.
Like sitting at a whiteboard table with 64
kittens and a pink leopard print wallet.
And as always -- thanks for watching.